he was once a close united states ally
but has now been extradited to face drug
trafficking charges in new york city
when orlando hernandez was being held at
a special forces military base in
honduras capital te ui sigalpa
he was transferred in the middle of a
massive security operation to an air
force airport where he was taken in a
u.s drug enforcement agency plane back
to the u.s
he's accused of conspiring to smuggle
hundreds of tons of drugs to the united
states hernandez and his co-conspirators
help push 500 000 kilograms of cocaine
into the united states
that's 500 tons of cocaine
poison that landed in this country on
our streets
and as we allege in the indictment
that's exactly what hernandez wanted
we allege that during a meeting with the
co-conspirator hernandez declared that
he wanted and i quote
to stuff the drugs right up the noses of
the gringos
hernandez says he is innocent and that
justice will prevail
i want to share some potent words
injustices are a threat to justice in
every place you know i worked tirelessly
with the purpose of recovering peace in
honduras i gave all my effort to my
country it is regrettable that those who
turn honduras into one of the most
violent countries in the world those
villains now want to be heroes
when orlando hernandez was elected
president in 2014
while in office he was considered
partner of the u.s and was loaded for
his alleged efforts to fight drug
trafficking and illegal migration
his mandate ended earlier this year and
was detained 19 days after leaving
office
his brother tony hernandez was sentenced
to life in prison in the u.s on drug
trafficking charges
during his brother's trial prosecutors
claimed mexican drug lord joaquin chapo
guzman handed the hernandez brothers one
million dollars for the presidential
campaign
lawyers in honduras say corruption has
infiltrated the highest levels of
honduras state and they need
international help to clean it up
the concentration of power we saw while
hernandez was in office weakened all the
institutions and the country now needs
to repair
we need to do lots of structural reforms
to improve our judiciary
we have requested help from the u n to
help us do this
hernandez extradition is the first time
a former president is to be tried on
drug trafficking charges in the u.s
many fear that the possibility of a u.s
trial will deter politicians in the
region from colluding with criminal
organizations ever again
terisa